you're young guy you're working with
Chris Pratt and I'm thinking did he give
you any advice I mean he's the he's sort
of the action hero star of the movie did
he give you advice on any acting tips or
anything like that yeah you know it's
funny you asked because he did he gave
me a couple of tips I actually I think I
saw him on your show he may have
demonstrated just a kind of a sneak T
yeah yeah he showed me some of the stuff
that he likes to do in the movie yeah
yeah he he's really he's not into
overacting so he likes to keep things
kind of on the level you know and very
similar so each face is kind of there's
a progression there I think he has like
three phases everything he has three
phases that's all great he'll only use
three phases yeah exactly I just
remember that it was like the first few
days on set and he kind of gave me on
his secret the first one was like oh
[ __ ] I left the oven on right and then
there was like oh my god I'm gonna die
right and then there was I love you I
think when you think about it you can
boil all acting into yeah which works
with a left the oven on dinosaurs are
coming absolute and then the face that
goes with a laptop yeah and then I love
you I don't I've been married a long
time I don't know what the I love you
face looks like I don't know either
honestly I I'm still kind of figuring
that out but he absolutely yeah he knows
what he's doing when it comes to that
kind of stuff wait is this this is a
picture from you from Jurassic world is
this a face that was inspired yeah yeah
I love
as I love you written although that is
why I love you face ah no that was I
think I think it's possible I may have
overdone it just a touch remember that
she knew it gather on that bubble and
your being about to be eaten by a
dinosaur I think that's an appropriate
face to make when you're in that
situation